The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi there.
I'm Brian.
We're going to be doing problem
number 7 of the 2009
final examination.
So the way I like to approach
these problems is to identify
what I think is important to
know before attempting them.
Things that you should review
that will help you
successfully navigate
the problem.
I call this the what
I need, W I N.
So for this particular problem,
which I think of as
the phase diagram problem, you
need three things critically
in order to successfully
complete it.
Number one you need to have a
general understanding of what
a phase diagram is, how to read
it, how to write it, how
to interpret the information
it gives you.
You can find a lot of this in
chapter 9 of Shackleford.
Along the same lines you should
probably know how to go
in between binary and unary
phase diagrams. How they are
related at least. In this
problem it's not absolutely
necessary to know this.
But in similar problems we might
ask, this is critical to
understand how these two
are interrelated.
The second thing you should
know is some language like
critical point and
triple point.
Where these are and what they
mean on the phase diagram.
And the third thing is the
phase coexistence.
So what does that
actually mean?
How do you find it on
the phase diagram?
So with these three particular
points, I'd review them and
then I would recommend
attempting the problem
afterwards.
So we're going to start
the problem.
We're going to start
over here.
I'm actually going to start this
from a reverse direction.
And review really quick what
a binary phase diagram is.
because this is actually the
phase diagram which you will
see most often as you progress
in your career as a scientist
or an engineer.
This is something you'll
see a lot of the time.
It'll have either one element
and another element.
Or one compound and another
compound along the axis.
And it shows the different
phases which exist at certain
temperatures and compositions.
So in general it's important
to sort of understand
what a phase is.
So a phase, is a chemically and
a structurally homogeneous
material given certain
state conditions.
So a phase diagram depicts
picks all these phases.
It's the master plot of phases
that are in equilibrium given
a particular set of
state conditions.
When I say state conditions
I'm actually referring to
things like temperature,
pressure, I even sometimes
consider composition to be one
of those state conditions.
So in a binary phase diagram,
what we're looking at is the
temperature versus
the composition.
So if you have some composition
of silicon and
germanium at some temperature,
you know exactly what phase it
should be at thermodynamically.
It doesn't actually mean it
will be, but it should be.
So that's what a binary phase
diagram looks like.
So this is something you'll
see a lot and this is
something you probably will
become used to seeing a lot as
you go on in your years.
We're going to come back
to this in a second.
But first, for now, we're going
to it actually attempt
the problem that's given.
And then I'll tie both of
those together for you.
So let's go over and
let's actually look
at the problem now.
We'll go back to that
in a second.
We're asked to draw a unary
phase diagram for silicon.
And we're given some critical
information.
Specifically on the problem
we're given the triple point,
we're given the critical
point, and we're
asked to draw this.
Not to scale, of course,
but what it should
generally look like.
So the first thing I do
is label my axes.
Pressure, temperature.
And then we're given
certain data.
So I'm just going to throw it
down right in the beginning.
We're given pressure and
temperature for triple point.
We're given pressure
and temperature for
the critical point.
So I'm going to put those
points down right now.
Because I know that's
part of the answer.
So let me first put down
the triple point.
We're told the triple point
occurs at 0.15 atm.
And we're told that that is at a
temperature of 1415 celsius.
So temperatures are going
to be in celsius and our
pressures are going to
be in atmospheres.
So we're going to go up
to find this point.
In fact I'm going to give
it a different color.
That is our triple point.
I'm next going to plot the
critical point here.
We're told that that occurs
at a pressure of 6,600.
So not to scale of course.
But that's going to be somewhere
all the way up here.
Now we're told that that is
at a temperature of 4880.
So here's a point here.
So we've just put
two points down.
But that's not enough to
complete the problem.
It doesn't actually answer
all the questions.
The problem actually also asks
us to provide the normal
boiling point and the normal
melting point of silicon.
So you're not actually given
those temperatures because
you've got to be clever.
And all the students in our
class are given a periodic
table during the exam.
So I would encourage you to
have a periodic table with
this type of data.
So if you look at the periodic
table for silicon you can then
find your melting point
and you can find
your boiling point.
So this data, a normal melting
point and a normal boiling
point will occur at
1 atmosphere.
Let me just put 1 atmosphere
on the pressure here.
Again not to scale.
So anything that occurs at this
particular pressure, this
isobaric line, is going
to be normal.
So our normal melting point
occurs at 1414, which is right
next to 1415.
There we go.
And our normal boiling
point occurs at 3265.
These are approximate numbers.
So we'll put that here.
And now if you've seen a unary
phase diagram before, which I
hope you have during your
studying, you'll know that it
looks somewhat like a y shape.
So one thing we're going to do
now is we're going to connect
these dots.
We know that at very high
temperatures we're going to
have what's a gas, basically.
And at very low temperatures
we're going to have something
like a solid.
And we have some liquid
in the middle.
And the way we're going to
delineate these phases is to
connect these dots.
And this is what our unary
phase diagram is
going to look like.
So in order to complete this
problem-- it was actually not
too bad of a problem-- all you
have to do is label some
particular aspects
of this graph.
So number 1, we have a solid
region, we have a gas region.
That implies this must
be the liquid region.
I'll put an L there.
You're asked to identify 1,
2 and 3 component regions.
Or three 1-phase regions,
2-phase regions.
So number 1, you could have
chosen for a 1-phase region,
you can chosen a point here in
the gas, a point here in the
liquid, or a point here
in the solid.
I'll just choose
one in the gas.
So something here, let's call
that i, for answering part i.
You could have chosen a point
along any of these lines for a
2-phase equilibrium.
Which implies that at that
point, so at that specific
pressure and at that specific
temperature, you have both
phases of equilibrium.
Let me just choose one
and explain it.
So let's choose something
here.
Between 0.15 and 1.
So let's choose this point.
There we are.
So at this point, at whatever
pressure we're at and whatever
temperature we're at here, we
have both liquid and gas in
equilibrium.
They both coexist. You're
not tending
towards one or the other.
They're both there.
So that's part B, the 2-phase
coexistence area.
So we put that here.
i i.
And the third part
is the 3-phase
coexistence, which is--
almost you can pull it out of
the name-- the triple point.
At the triple point-- and
there's only one of these--
you have all three,
gas, liquid and
solid coexisting together.
So we've already sort
of made that.
That was our blue dot.
1, 2, 3.
That's that point right there.
So not to scale.
But this is the answer.
This is full credit.
One thing that's really
interesting to note is that on
this particular answer we have
a negative slope on our
solid-liquid coexistence line.
Now you've probably seen this
before in your studying and it
occurred with water.
Most materials actually will
have a positive slope.
If you think about it it's
sort of counterintuitive.
What this implies is that if I'm
at a constant temperature
and as I raise my pressure I'm
going to go from the solid to
the liquid.
Intuitively, we would think that
the solid is more densely
packed and therefore as we
increase the pressure we're
going to tend towards a solid.
That's not the case in water and
in this problem is not the
case with the data we're
given for silicon.
In this case as we raise the
pressure we're actually
turning into a liquid.
It's kind of counterintuitive.
Another way of actually saying
that is the liquid phase at
this particular temperature
is more dense
than the solid phase.
And you see that with water,
which is why ice
floats on top of water.
So that is our unary diagram.
That is the full credit
on this problem.
I do want to tie it in really
quick though, with what a
binary diagram is.
Because this is a very important
concept to get and a
potential problem.
So we're going to go back
over to binary phase
diagram over here.
And so what we're looking at on
this binary phase diagram
is actually, it's the
temperature versus the
composition at a specific
pressure.
Now for a binary phase diagram
you're going to assume--
unless you're told otherwise--
that it occurs at 1
atm, 1 atmosphere.
If I want to go between the
binary and the unary that we
just looked at, you need
to add your third axis.
So if we had a third axis--
let me draw that here.
This is going to
be our z-axis.
There's the z.
We know that if we put a
pressure along this axis,
we're going to be able to
extract what we had for our
unary diagram.
So let me do that for you.
I'm going to call this
the pressure axis.
Going back in and out
of the board.
And actually this is at 1 atm.
Which implies at some
point farther
back we have the origin.
You can just do this
lightly so it
doesn't get too confusing.
We have an origin for
our pressure.
So at this point we
have 0 pressure.
We don't work with negative
pressures.
0 pressure.
Which implies-- let me just
draw the Cartesian form of
this-- so we have composition,
we have
temperature, we have pressure.
That's our x, y, z.
Now what happens is that as we
increase pressure what happens
to, for example, this point?
Now what is this point?
This point is the point
where we go from the
solid to the liquid.
That's the melting point.
What happens to the melting
point as we increase or
decrease our pressure?
Well that information is given
on our unary phase diagram.
Let's go back really quickly.
As we increase our pressure we
can see that what's going to
happen with our point is
it's going to go up.
So what basically we have to
do is we need to take-- you
have to think
three-dimensionally--
and take this graph and you're
going to take it an spin it
and put it on to one of
those planes there.
So we're going to get an idea.
This is something that I would
challenge you, the listener,
to do and think about and do
on your paper after you've
completed this problem
successfully.
I'm going to draw
it right now.
And I'm going to let you
look at it and think
about it, what it means.
So let me do that.
Let's take a look now.
This is our temperature axis.
Here's t.
Here's p.
Remember unary was p versus
t, so you've got
to do a little flipping.
But let me just draw it now.
It kind of goes up
to the words.
But you get the idea.
This is-- if you do a little
flipping and I challenge you
to do that, some
three-dimensional thinking--
this is the unary phase plot
that we gave for our answer.
And the point I'm trying to
make is that you can go in
between your unary and your
binary diagrams by
understanding that.
For example, binary diagram is
at a constant pressure and
your unary diagram, unary
means that it has one
material, one composition.
So in this particular problem
I've created germanium to be
our b element.
And we're operating here
with pure silicon.
So you can go in between
if you have the
grasp of that concept.
So I would challenge you
to think about that.
If you've gotten the problem
right and you understand this
concept, I think you're good
to go on phase diagrams.